les auteurs de la profanation de
saint-herblain arrêté il s'agit de trois
s'ils existent ont été présentés au
parquet masqué par des cagoules pour
éviter toute vengeance
un mort pour une allemagne le traité
d'union monétaire a été signé
aujourd'hui c'est la première étape
concrète de la réunification des deux
allemagnes
philippe legorjus invité du 19/20
l'ancien commandant du gign évoquera la
sphère de la grotte d'ouvéa l'occasion
de la sortie de son livre la morale et
l'action
enfin le festival de cannes avec deux
films événements nouvelle vague de
baudart aujourd'hui et si renault de
rappeneau demain interview exclusive de
gérard depardieu à la veille de son
arrivée sur la croisette
bonsoir skinheads ce terme par et
barbare il signifie en anglais crâne
rasé il est apparu il ya quelques années
en france aient été importées si j'ose
dire par deux jeunes garçons proche de
l'extrême droite et faisant volontiers
le coup de poing et bien ce sont trois
skinheads qui ont profané le cimetière
chrétien de saint-herblain près de
nantes
il avait brisé de nombreuses croix et
laisser des inscriptions étrange le pen
à mort une carpentras vengeance sans
doute pour donner le change il se
trouvait plus quelques heures au palais
de justice de nantes
alors on gère comme à carpentras ils
sont venus dire leur révolte
mais l'heure est corman est encore plus
amer ici ceux qui ont profané les tombes
sont identifiés et ils font partie de la
bonne société nantaise chez eux
l'arsenal du parfait néonazis 20 ans 22
ans lycéen employés on les prenait pour
des jeunes gens bien sous tous rapports
mais derrière une façade sociale bien
lisse l'envers du décor 3
inconditionnels du troisième reich qui
collectionnait c'est arsenal macabre
vigueur revolver crochet de boucher
barres de fer et par tous et croix
celtiques si proche des croix gammées
d'il ya 40 ans
carpentras avait choqué les trois jeunes
gens nés pour une raison inverse de la
révolte unanime de ces derniers jours en
saccageant le cimetière de
saint-herblain eux voulaient protester
contre l'arrestation de suspects
d'extrême droite et faire porter le
chapeau à l'extrême gauche d'où leur
stratégie barbouillé les tombes
d'inscription qui le pen maquiller leur
forfait comme un acte de vengeance juive
ce soir du ton monte face et leurs
cicatrices et les trois nostalgiques ont
manqué leur cible les skinheads font
parler d'eux de temps en temps lors de
raids ou de bagarres à caractère raciste
mais qui sont ils vraiment des paumés en
mal de violence ou de jeunes militants
politiques
éric thibault a tenté de le savoir
17 heures nous avons rendez vous avec 15
qui n'aide un dissident skinheads et un
troisième qui ne revendique aucune
appartenance à un mouvement pourtant un
point commun les caractérise tous les
3èmes la violence
un peu d'objets relance quoi parce que
tout le monde a sa dose de violence un
peu de violence mais galan canaliser à
certains endroits certains moments
d'affluence calculé juste pourtant tu
sais que tu es inquiète
selon lui ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
français tout le français moyen le
français tout le monde le beauf
ouais je sais que c'est inquiète ces
gens là mais ce qu'il faut qu'ils voyent
quoi c'est que ce nouveau concept a
entre nous dans la jeunesse quand on
tape les nazis vedette s'est pas
démocratique quoi mais on n'a jamais dit
qu'on était démocrate chaque groupe a
ses codes ses lieux de réunion secret
les chefs tiennent des fichiers sur les
mouvements ennemis
mais pour eux carpentras ce n'est pas
les skinheads
je pense qu'on n'est pas les vautours
quoi je vois si les gens une panse choc
aux médias
imposez-vous tous peut on pas chercher
quelque chose qui est déjà mort
programme de leur week-end achats dans
les surplus anglais concerts et si
l'occasion se présente
la castagne en revanche l'enquète n'a
toujours pas progressé à carpentras
comme à royan à royan où en ce moment
même des centaines de personnes
manifestent leur indignation mais aussi
leur solidarité à christian guillard sos
racisme des syndicats d'enseignants des
parents d'élèves mais aussi des anonymes
ont voulu protester vigoureusement
contre cette agression
quelques heures plus tôt le directeur le
recteur de l'académie de poitiers venait
symboliquement assuré le cours
d'instruction civique
face aux élèves de christian guillard
dans la classe même du professeur
agressé en début de semaine il a fait
l'historique de la liberté en france ont
condamné en condamnant très fermement la
violence
nous sommes tous des métis a conclu le
recteur
reportage fr3 poitiers
73 élèves des classes de troisième de
chritine guillard ont assisté ce matin
au cours du recteur de l'académie de
poitiers une bonne dizaine de
journalistes mais avant de parler de
carpentras il a dû faire une mise au
point sur le rôle des enseignants
il est facile nous accuser de sortir de
notre rôle est de nous immiscer dans la
politique
notre mission est aussi de préparer des
citoyens responsables
à l'entrée dans la vie adulte le recteur
a développé son cours sur deux thèmes la
devise de la république liberté égalité
fraternité et la notion de la nation
c'est léopold sédar senghor l'ancien
président de la république du sénégal
pour être que vous connaissez qui dit
nous sommes tous des métis n'y a pas en
france de citoyenneté à plusieurs
vitesses une heure de cours pour
rappeler que la france a été le premier
pays au monde à proclamer l'égalité des
citoyens quelle que soit leur origine ou
leur religion
un discours que certains élèves ont eu
du mal à suivre je trouve que c'est pas
trop rapport l'escale et des médias
je n'ai pas à la loi de 1972 hippie la
déclaration des droits de l'homme puis
c'est un peu confection nous quoi l'on
paie des grands mots tout ça n'a pas
tout suivi
c'était pas très en principe aujourd'hui
les d'élèves du collège émile-zola de
royan vont tenter de reprendre leurs
études
loin de l'agitation mais rien ne sera
jamais plus comme avant
l'intolérance a fait irruption au milieu
de la cour
ces événements ont été une nouvelle fois
évoqué par françois mitterrand polynésie
le chef de l'état a tenu à préciser les
raisons pour lesquelles il s'était rendu
à la bastille et a lancé un nouvel appel
au consensus
sisi pe défilé pas mon rôle
mais je suis allé là où le défilé devait
séparer pour saluer ses initiateurs et
ce qui est clair je pense à vos yeux
je pense qu'il savait raison de marquer
refus gare de ces terribles excès du
racisme même dans chaque formation
politique est responsable devant
l'opinion devant ses adhérents
cet appel sera sans doute entendu par
tous les partis modérés de droite et de
gauche la condamnation de l'extrême
droite semble être unanime jacques
chirac l'a souligné une nouvelle fois
mais le président du rpr n'a pas voulu
éluder ce qu'il a appelé hier la
responsabilité de françois mitterrand et
les revenus sur l'état de la droite face
à l'extrême droite cet après midi au
cours des états généraux de l'opposition
écoutons le j'ai pour ma part deux
certitudes
la première c'est que nos électeurs ne
supporte plus nos divisions à nous
à nous de répondre à leurs attentes et
la deuxième c'est que l'affaiblissement
actuel de l'opposition et
l'accroissement de l'extrême droite sont
dus en partie et c'est notre
responsabilité à nos divisions
philippe legorjus bonsoir vous écoutiez
attentivement ce soir tous nos
reportages que pensez vous de ce climat
de violence je rappelle que vous êtes
l'ancien commandant du gign écoutez ce
climat de violence me rappelle et
malheureusement des actes de violence
que j'ai eu à connaître lorsque j'étais
patron du gign actes de violence plus
redoutable encore peut-être puisque
c'étaient des actes qui généralement
emporté la mort de certaines personnes
mais ce que je vois aujourd'hui c'est
aussi une violence contre l'esprit
et lorsque l'on en est à ce stade on
n'est pas loin de ce qu'on a pu
connaître une aussi alors philippe
legorjus on vous a invité pour un livre
que vous venez d'écrire la morale et
l'action publié par les éditions fit
chaud je lui ai dit tout à l'heure vous
étiez le commandant du gène à 34 ans et
vous avez été l'un des acteurs du drame
d'ouvea lors votre livre se lit comme un
roman mais c'est pas un roman c'est un
récit la prise d'otages oui je crois pas
que ce soit uniquement un récit de prise
d'otage je crois que j'ai voulu au delà
des faits essayer de voir comment on
pouvait à partir de règles de règles
morales que l'on peut s'imposer
personnellement ou que l'on respecte
dans la vie en société
on pouvait confronter ces règles à des
phénomènes de violence comme ceux dont
on vient de parler et à trouver des
moyens à la fois techniques et moraux de
résoudre ces problèmes de violence alors
bien sûr la sphère d'ouvéa philippe
legorjus où vous avez été vous étiez
bien sûr le commandant du gign vous avez
aussi joué un rôle très politique
pendant ces événements n'ont à mon
niveau je ne considère pas que c'est un
rôle politique lorsque vous avez à
traiter une affaire de prise d'otages
vous essayez de la traiter dans sa
globalité afin d'obtenir le meilleur
résultat possible
alors effectivement vous prenez en
compte les paramètres politiques
et si vous vous apercevez un moment ou
un autre du traitement de la crise qu'il
faut aussi jouer d'une façon ou d'une
autre sur le politique bien vous le
faites je crois qu'il faut pas avoir de
regrets par rapport à ça c'est parce que
je considère de ses pas une attitude
marginal
désobéissante par rapport à des règles
établies c'est la volonté de prendre
tous les moyens pour arjen solution de
libération d'otages
mais vous étiez très perturbé par la
coïncidence entre ce drame d'ouvea
l'élection présidentielle
mais l'élection présidentielle était je
vais dire presque la cause de cette
prise d'otages
c'est parce qu'ils avaient l'élection
présidentielle très certainement que les
mélanésiens ont décidé d'attaquer la
brigade de firewall et d'assassiner
quatre gendarmes aussi toi mais c'est
tout de même vous qui avait tenu
l'elysée au courant j'ai tenu au courant
at il dit dans un livre
tout à fait j'ai tenu au courant un
homme à l'elysée c'est ce que je dis
dans le livre cet homme s'appelle
christian prouteau
il est le fondateur du gign et
contrairement à ce qu'on a pensé
j'ai toujours cru que le gouvernement de
l'époque informées normalement par les
voies normales et lisez ce que je
voulais c'est que le président à travers
christian prouteau et est vraiment une
appréciation je veux dire presque
psychologique et intimiste de la façon
dont vous pouvez résoudre le problème
vous parlez souvent de violences dans
votre livre dans votre vie mais ce n'est
pas le sentiment que la politique est
quelque fois encore plus violentes qu'on
imagine lesquels je sers quelquefois non
j'ai pas vraiment cette impression moss
est aujourd'hui à travers l'action qui
était la mienne comme chef du gign
j'ai établi une réflexion et cette
réflexion ce qu'il faut aider au
contraire le politiques à résoudre
techniquement et en dehors de toute
contingence je sais pas si le mot est
bien choisi essayer de bien résoudre de
bien visionnez la
la finalité de respect de la vie et de
la mort par rapport aux acteurs des
unités d'intervention comme celle que je
demande c'est curieux vous semblait à la
fois lucide et un petit peu quand dit
est ce que vraiment la morale à sa place
dans l'action et est ce que vraiment
l'amour à la sa place dans l'action
politique
je crois que la morale à sa place dans
la vie tout court quelle que soit la
forme cette vie merci philippe legorjus
cet officiel et historique les deux
allemagnes n'en forment plus qu'une au
moins dans le domaine économique et
monétaire le traité a été signé
aujourd'hui et cette fois c'est la
première étape complète de la
réunification allemande sept mois jour
pour jour après les premiers événements
l'allemagne de l'est bascule donc sans
transition du communisme au capitalisme
marie-hélène tichot fin d'un règne la
conséquence de la chute du mur de berlin
la réunification allemande se fait par
le deutsche mark
le chancelier kohl a déclaré
c'est une heure historique dans la vie
de la nation allemande l'union monétaire
économique et social entrera en vigueur
le 1er juillet par ce traité
l'allemagne de l'est acceptent
l'économie de marché la modeste
allemande disparaît remplacé par le
deutsche mark
un marc de l'ess vaudra un marc de
l'ouest pour les salaires les bourses
les retraites les loyers pour le reste
le change est fixé à 2 pour 1 au
quotidien la vie des allemands de l'est
va être bouleversée le salaire moyen de
l'est et 2000 marque soit 3500 francs
soit trois fois moins qu'à l'ouest
le traité prévoit la suppression à plus
ou moins long terme des subventions
conséquence les loyers aujourd'hui
dérisoire augmenteront même chose pour
l'alimentation en revanche les allemands
de l'est pourront acheter des
téléviseurs importer jusqu'à maintenant
ils devaient se contenter des
téléviseurs made in rda excessivement
cher détails du quotidien bouleversement
de l'économie les experts prévoient un
accroissement du chômage à l'est le
traité prévoit que la rfa et de rats la
rda à couvrir les dépenses d assurance
chômage
la démocratie la vraie progresse en
roumanie malgré les turbulences trois
jours avant les premières élections
libres
les roumains ont eu droit à un vrai
débat télévisé entre les trois candidats
à la présidence ils ont sans doute eu le
sentiment de changer de planète
reportage de notre envoyé spécial mémona
hintermann
20 heures du jamais vu ici un débat en
direct entre les trois têtes d'affiché
sont de salut national parti libéral
parti paysan face à son principal
adversaire radu comme p ain où le leader
des libéraux yann il échoue parle
surtout d'économie il s'efforce de
sourire en permanence
il regrette dit il le mauvais climat de
campagne le son du débat et retransmis
en direct par les contestataires place
de l'université il a dit en avoir aussi
aujourd'hui l'appui de huit millions de
signataires la moitié du corps électoral
je crois que c'est une chose très bon
c'est fait bas mais je suis convaincu
que cette élection sont déjà à ranger et
le public qui vote pour du temps de
ceausescu avait bien mettre sous la dent
même ans ils ont quelque chose à bouffer
ils sont contents sont des gens très
simples vous êtes qui vous bon ça c'est
moins un peu les allées voter
nous vous présentions justement d'hier
le portrait du grand favori de ces
élections il y ait ce coup gros plan ce
soir sur l'un de ses opposants
llodra thiou il est le candidat du parti
national paysans d'accès par la majorité
des roumains d'être le candidat de
l'étranger il n'est revenu à bucarest
qu'en janvier dernier après 50 ans
d'exil à l'ouest portraits réalisés par
nos envoyés spéciaux
philippe pisteurs et marc d'où la maison
jaune radio à bucarest dans le quartier
des ambassades
le candidat du parti national paysans
arrive tout juste d'un meeting une
surprise l'attend rencontre avec deux
vieux copains de régiment il ya une
réaction est seulement rentrer au pays
en janvier dernier après 50 ans d'exil
1940 il vient d'être nommé à l'ambassade
roumaine à londres la guerre éclate la
roumanie s'allie à l'allemagne nazie il
demande alors l'asile politique
quand vient le communisme il décide de
rester en bretagne
c'est là qu'il épouse elisabeth
pilkington riche héritière une femme
anglais cinquante ans d'absence lourd
handicap en roumanie certains parlent de
lui comme du candidat de l'étranger tous
à neige était toujours militaire aux
mains d'organisations la compagnie
j'écris des livres
beaucoup de livres et en radio est
notamment président de l'union mondiale
des roumains libre une désorganisation
de l'exil est l'un des fondateurs
d'amnesty international d'abord
journaliste après la guerre il s'est
lancé dans les affaires avec succès
c'est un homme très entouré pour ne pas
dire très protégé étrange pratique pour
une campagne électorale les lieux de la
plupart de ses meetings sont tenus
secret dévoilé au dernier moment parce
que l'épée menacé même foi
vous vous rappelez on a tâché de me
lâcher et c'est aucun doute pour lui le
responsable organisateurs de ces
intimidations
c'est le front antinational pour
l'empêcher de parler et dans ses
meetings il parle il parle de la morale
chrétienne de la redistribution des
terres collectives aux paysans de la
libre entreprise de l'apport des
capitaux étrangers qui ne manquerait pas
d'affluer s'il était élu il se propose
également d'organiser un référendum
oui ou non le retour du roi michel van
den de faire la constitution romaine on
doit décider si on veut pas voir avec
public mandat chez quoi ces deux finales
le candidat ratio n'aime pas faire de
pronostics surtout quant à ses chances
pour la présidentielle
gorbatchev a fait un pas en direction de
la lituanie il a bien voulu recevoir à
moscou le premier ministre lituanien
mais sur le fond sa position n'a pas
changé cela déçoit
garry kasparov le champion du monde
d'échecs et de passage à paris est
favorable lui à l'autodétermination des
républiques baltes
il s'est confié à jean philippe bien au
sein des taux
niveau 515,3 km/heure le tgv n'en finit
plus de repousser les limites de vitesse
sur rail ce matin un nouveau record du
monde a été pulvérisée un exploit pour
les cheminots et une avance décisive
pour la sncf dans la conquête des
marchés à l'exportation en particulier
pour le marché sud coréen
le tgv a décidément beaucoup de talent
jean jacques peyraud des cheminots
confiants dans leurs machines au point
de tenter un dernier record ce matin
sous les yeux de leur ministre de
tutelle et de la presse la machine
la fameuse ram 325 ne les trahira pas
500 tous
166 4 515,3 le record absolu de vitesse
sur rail était déjà été depuis six mois
cette fois il est pulvérisé pour la sncf
c'est un atout décisif pour la conquête
des marchés étrangers
le tgv viennent prouver de façon
éclatante la réserve de puissance est la
marge de sécurité dont ils disposent en
service normal car il faut rappeler que
cette rame 325 n'est pas un prototype
dès septembre elle accueillera des
passagers sur le réseau atlantique mais
à 300 km heure seulement
hervé dino présente les autres
événements du jour couverts par notre
réseau régional de couler de boules du
mu à de violents orages a provoqué ce
matin le déraillement du train ni genève
à hauteur de vos yeux l'hiver le
conducteur de la motrice qui s'est
écrasé à 30 mètres en contrebas du talus
a été tué sur le coup
on ne déplore aucun blessé parmi la
centaine de passagers les voitures du
train n'ayant pas quitté les rails
le tribunal administratif a rejeté le
recours en indemnisation des époques
warez contre le chr de nice qui en 1987
avait affirmé annick warez que le foetus
qu'elle portait était totalement normal
pourtant quelques semaines plus tard
elle donnait naissance à un enfant
mongolien le tribunal a considéré que la
faute du chr n'était pas prouvée
pourtant dans une affaire semblable à
montpellier la petite klm a obtenu une
rente à vie
les passagers de l'estérel qui assure
les liaisons entre nice et calvi ont été
bloqués durant 18 heures au port ce
n'est qu'une fois montés à bord qu'ils
ont appris que les six officiers avaient
décidé de bloquer le bateau pour obtenir
des indemnités compensatoires plus
importante
les négociations entre la direction et
les grévistes ayant permis de régler le
litige les stoehr elle a pu enfin
prendre la mer visite douleureuse pour
philippe gillet au muséum d'histoire
naturelle de nantes où il vient déposer
des derniers spécimens de sa collection
de reptiles ses voisins ne goûtant guère
sa passion pour les serpents ont obtenu
que les 30 rampant qu'il ait loupé dans
son appartement mais soit retirée philip
schyle et ne peut plus que venir les
voir chaque jour et les nourrir il a pu
aussi conservé chez lui une maman python
qui couve actuellement sa portée en
tennis c'est la fin d'une très belle
série pour guy forget aux internationaux
de roms malgré quelques superbes
passings le français vient de s'incliner
face à l'autrichien thomas muster 6 2 3
6 6 3 malgré cette défaite forget
conforte sa place de numéro un français
à moins de 15 jours de roland garros et
on va conclure ce 19 ans avec deux
événements qui marqueront dès demain le
festival de cannes avec tout d'abord la
présentation de cyrano de bergerac de
jean paul rappeneau aura-t-il à cannes
le succès qu'il remporte en ville et
dans toutes les villes de france
on le souhaite pour rappeneau et pour
gérard depardieu qui se trouve en ce
moment même à new york qui sera calme
demain et qui a accordé aux 19 à une
interview exclusive il nous parle de
cannes
il parla jean pierre lavoignat de cannes
où sera demain moi c'est ça beaucoup
sable csa plein de choses car c'est la
première fois où j'ai été voir la mer 20
dans la province et un autre cache la
forêt travail et de la mer en étant
plagistes je me suis retrouvé quatre ans
après avoir sonné sur les plages de
cannes dans avec eux en 76 74 69 69 74
76 avec novecento bon il y avait les
valseuses avant la première fois c'était
pour les valseuses dans un comm ca c
c'est quelque chose d'unique beaucoup
canada je trouve que d'être à cannes
avec cyrano de bergerac avec où son prix
moi ça m'est complètement égal
on a tous à cannes on a eu la palme d'or
avec maurice qu'était un film magnifique
on a eu des prix d'interprétation avec
avec michel blanc des jurys avec ferreri
et albert contrôle rebelle
on a on a eu plein jour samantha jamais
eu le prix toi donc moi c'est pour moi
c'est comment dire c'est vrai c'est pas
de la fausse modestie fille sait très
bien que comment dire d'avoir des prix
mais oh c'est pas ça le plus important
pour nous c'est d'essayer rencontre à
cannes avec six autres bergerac crois
que c'est l'un des plus beau pour moi
c'est la plus belle consécration parce
que en plus de lettres à pas est en
sorti comme ça avec avec cet amour du
public avec cet amour de ce sens fin
qu'on a qu'on a réussi son bien travail
quoi on a bien travaillé plus belle des
choses
second événement l'arrivée d'alain delon
à cannes on l'a attendu toute la journée
on ne l'attendait plus mais finalement
il est venu par la mer sachant très bien
qu'ils se faisait désirer pour le disait
brouillé avec godard
on ne sait pas s'ils vont se
réconciliant on sera sans doute écrit
ceux qui disent ça sont des cons voilà
voilà ça sent bien la réconciliation la
réconciliation puisque alain delon venez
rejoindre jean-luc godard revenu dès ce
matin pour la première projection de son
film
dominique poncet christophe airaud n'ont
pas résisté au plaisir de suivre la
journée du réalisateur de nouvelles
vagues faivre inhabituel ce matin aux
marches du palais en cours ou pour
assister à la projection de nouvelles
vagues maison cour pour qui pour de long
la star ou godard le cinéaste veut
servir et vous vous attendez à quoi
avec belvédère ont pesé comme on peut
s'attendre à tout effectivement on
pouvait s'attendre à tout car le texte
du dossier de presse faisait plutôt dans
l'abstrait
une heure trente plus tard les cote
d'amour de longueau d'art n'étaient pas
tout à fait un rêve c est presque nuls
comme d'habitude nul à nu c'est très
bien de lons mais les trouver comment
une a pour but moi je trouve plus de
l'onf est un peu d'épicerie mais enfin
on ne pas leur dire de loire là dedans
puis à l'intérieur godard fait enfin son
entrée dans la salle de conférence pour
se prêter plutôt de mauvais gré
d'ailleurs aux questions des
journalistes
mais si godard considérez vous votre
film est une réalité ou en cauchemar
vous devriez réfléchir longtemps pour
poser la vraie question est que moi je
sois pas obligée après de bafouiller un
peu des banalités comme ça je voudrais
vous demander si vous n'avez pas
l'impression malgré tout avoir réalisé
votre plus mauvais film mais cette
étrange que vous deviez parce que un
moment au mental j'ai eu l'impression
j'ai dit ça sera peut-être mon premier
mauvais film
et puis j'ai essayé de savoir s'il y
avait dans ce mot mauvais est ce qu'il y
avait de bons c'est un film par an que
je me suis pas mis en souvenir d'un
boulot je me suis permis au générique et
le temps demain en france sera l'image
de cette conférence de presse
lourd et orageux avec tout de même je
vous rassure quelques éclaircies il faut
garder de la 3 ce soir après la classe
à 20h35 thalassa le magazine de georges
pernoud qui nous amène en norvège
prochain rendez vous avec la fossette à
22h30 soir 3 présenté par mark de man
fin de ce 19 20 à lundi 19 rebonds soir
bon week-end
c'est mieux
bon